the movie opens up with a woman named
Jamie who is on a date with a guy named
Adam during their romantic dinner Jaime
expresses her wish to become a
professional kickboxer she wants to beat
up people for a living after the date
comes to an end the two kiss each other
before parting ways Upon returning home
Jamie unwinds in a bathtub while
conversing with her friend on the phone
as she is distracted an individual
wearing a mask infiltrates her house and
kidnaps her she just wasted a perfectly
good opportunity to beat someone up in
the next scene Jimmy regains her
Consciousness and finds herself locked
up in an unfamiliar vacant room with
only a CCTV camera attached on the
ceiling filled with fear she Taps on the
door appealing for assistance the door
opens revealing a dim hallway ahead she
nervously walks forward and soon comes
across another woman named Sabrina who
is dressed just like Jamie unable to
trust her Jamie forbids her from coming
closer to her but Sabrina claims that
she is also a victim following this as
the two are exploring the area the door
closes from behind try wrapping them
within a circular room suddenly Sabrina
says I'm sorry and the launches an
attack on Jaime the latter has no clue
what's going on but nonetheless she
fights back instigating an intense fight
between the two in the midst of the
commotion Jimmy asks for the reason why
she is doing this to which Sabrina
replies I deal eventually Sabrina pins
Jaime down and Strikes her with multiple
fatal blows resulting in her death in
anguish she cries out asking how many
more lives she has to take Jaime would
have made a terrible kickboxer the scene
then cuts to a couple Joseph and
Elizabeth who are revealed to be behind
all of this they have kidnapped several
women and are orchestrating deadly
battles among them they record all the
fights in the fighting chamber
broadcasting it live in front of their
rich clients it appears that they do it
for monetary gain by a wealthy folk in
exchange for their entertainment back in
the confinement Sabrina is woken up by
the distressed cries of other women
shortly after Joseph announces the
results of previous matches and also
chooses the next contenders it turns out
that the Fighter's family will live as
long as the fighters survive the fights
the game resumes and we see two other
women D and Phoebe making their way to
the same circular arena for the fight as
they head there D reveals that they've
threatened to harm her little sister to
which Phoebe responds that her mother's
life is on the line soon the battle
begins and Phoebe immediately gains the
upper hand she launches a brutal attack
on D resulting in her quick death
meanwhile her fellow inmate from another
cell named Cody attempts to strike up a
conversation with Sabrina she introduces
herself and reveals that when she was a
kid she witnessed her father's abuse
towards her mother this has left her
traumatized until today a short while
later the facility's guard leader Kurtz
enters Sabrina's cell to provide her
with some food he congratulates her for
her recent Victory due to which her
daughter will get to live one more day
in response Sabrina claims that she
doesn't have a daughter and she doesn't
care what they do with that little girl
unfortunately this angers Kurtz so he
pushes her against the wall and points a
gun to her head he warns her to mind her
language or else she won't get any
special favors from now on afterwards
six of the incarcerated women including
Sabrina and Phoebe are escorted out of
their cells and into a room where they
are bound to cherish as the guards leave
Phoebe starts to talk claiming that she
enjoys fighting and wondering how many
more she would kill unlike her all the
other women desperately want to get out
of this hell their conversations are
soon interrupted by Joseph and Elizabeth
Joseph informs them that they brought 50
women to the facility and only 22 are
left now Elizabeth then walks closer to
Sabrina and Praises her fighting prowess
while Phoebe Garner's favor from Joseph
according to the couple the final winner
will be chosen in three days and that
very Champion will be released from the
facility after the session the women are
LED back to their cells during which
Phoebe taught Sabrina this provocation
leads Sabrina to lose her temper and
launch a headbutt at Phoebe however the
guards soon separate them preventing any
further brawls later on another inmate
by the name of Theresa asks Sabrina if
she was in the military when the latter
replies with a yes she proposes that
they escape the facility their other
Ally Cody also agrees saying that all
they have to do is kill the guards
however Sabrina asserts that it's not
that easy because they as well as their
family members are under close
observation their tiny mistake could
risk the lives of their loved ones
overcome with emotion Sabrina begins to
cry as she reveals that she gave up her
child for adoption but now she is
constantly being monitored in the
following scene Cody is assigned to
fight an inmate named Marissa the rest
of the women watch the fight from a
small television screen in their cell
Cody somehow manages to defeat her
opponent by using a choking technique
after this Sabrina is forced to fight
consecutive death matches with two women
named Gloria and Alex but she manages to
win both of them regardless she is so
exhausted that she passes out on the
ground shortly after some guards walk
into the fight room and carry her away
meanwhile all of these live matches are
being streamed to the rich folks via a
large television screen Theresa is taken
away for the next fight and her opponent
is Rachel as the fight begins both of
them start punching each other but
Teresa eventually manages to take her
down feeling defeated Rachel in a crying
voice asks Teresa to relay the message
to her husband that she loves him a lot
Teresa nods her head and then judge oh
God and then chokes Rachel to death for
the next fight two women Anne and Brenda
are ordered to walk out of their cell
and cooperates but Brenda has a nervous
breakdown and refuses to fight when the
guards are unable to send them Kurtz
informs Elizabeth who then walks into
the facility in order to deal with the
situation upon approaching Brenda she
reminds her that the only way she can
save her mother is by cooperating and
agreeing to the fight Furious Brenda
strikes Elizabeth with a headbutt
causing her to bleed from her nose this
enrages Elizabeth and believing that
Brenda is not salvageable she shoots her
down she then comments on the need to
find a replacement as if this were
routine on the other hand Sabrina wakes
up and finds herself restrained on the
table she somehow manages to free
herself but before she can head to
another table full of knives she is
apprehended by a guard returning to
herself Sabrina tries to call out to her
allies Teresa and Cody but receives no
response unfortunately she soon learns
that the two are pitted against one
another fight in the fight chamber both
Cody and Teresa are unwilling to fight
each other Teresa wonders what will
happen if they simply refuse to fight in
response Cody explains that such
Defiance would result in the deaths of
both of them as well as their loved ones
Teresa then asks about Cody's mother but
she reluctantly punches her instead of
answering despite this Teresa doesn't
retaliate and instead proceeds to tell
her about her husband who is sick and is
in the Intensive Care Unit she says that
it will probably be a blessing if he
dies knowing how badly Cody needs her
Mother Teresa chooses to allow her to
win the fight they feign a fight during
which Teresa puts Cody's hand to her
neck instructing her to squeeze it
harder she then deliberately falls to
the floor allowing Cody to strangle her
to death as the fight ends Cody gets off
Teresa's body and breaks into tears
unfortunately she doesn't get much rest
as Phoebe is immediately ushered into
the fight chamber to confront her on
Route Phoebe taunts Sabrina saying that
she's going to kill her Alliance Sabrina
warns her to stay away from Cody but
Phoebe dismisses her and continues on
her way whistling upon entering the
fight chamber Phoebe continues her
mockery making provoking remarks about
her father's assault triggering Cody's
trauma this angers Cody who then starts
the fight beginning with a punch however
Phoebe is easily able to gain the upper
hand and beat her up brutally at last
she finishes Cody off by mercilessly
banging her head against the wall in the
aftermath of this incident Phoebe
asserts her desire to face off against
Sabrina back in herself Sabrina also
expresses her wish to confront Phoebe
and approaches Kurtz to request
permission to do so in response Kurtz
arrogantly says that she can fight as
much as she wants because they are going
to kill her daughter anyway following
this he returns to the control room and
unlocks Sabrina's cell door after which
she runs towards the fighting chamber
where Phoebe is waiting for her she
immediately launches an aggressive
assault on Phoebe channeling her anger
into the confrontation Sabrina delivers
some powerful blows knocking Phoebe to
the floor but the latter continues to
laugh this only fuels Sabrina's Fury
leading her to unleash even more
powerful punches and kicks ultimately
executing her after this Phoebe's body
is taken away but Sabrina is ordered to
stay in the fighting chamber because she
still has to fight one more opponent who
is a new replacement named Isabel Thomas
according to Joseph it is the first time
that the final fight will be taking
place against a newcomer he goes on to
say that Isabella is a former Collegiate
athlete who earned a full scholarship
she operates a gym that she owns with
her husband and also trains in Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu Joseph announces that the
Survivor of this fight will be declared
the ultimate Champion not long after as
Isabel walks into the fight chamber
Sabrina asks if she knows why she was
brought here Isabelle replies with a no
prompting Sabrina to explain the stakes
refusal or defeat would lead to the
death of their loved ones as expected
Isabel doesn't believe any of it so
Sabrina initiates the fight with a punch
in retaliation Isabelle tosses her to
the ground and manages to overpower her
with her fighting skill at one point
Isabelle has her hand around the neck
Sabrina who then asks her to do it
Isabelle then proceeds to twist
Sabrina's neck causing her to collapse
to the ground the fight ends and
Isabelle is declared as the Victor the
guards carry Sabrina's body and take it
to the morgue a short while later Joseph
and Elizabeth walk into the facility to
meet their winner before that they thank
Kurtz for his service and extend an
invitation for him to join a celebration
just outside the facility with all the
rich within the morgue chamber
as a staff member is about to attend to
Sabrina's body she unexpectedly wakes up
and stabs him with a knife here it is
revealed that Sabrina had staged her
death and she is now determined to
escape the facility moments later
another staff member enters the morgroom
and Sabrina slices his throat as well
she then cautiously walks out of the
room and starts killing the guards one
after another she eventually breaks into
the room where Joseph and Elizabeth are
addressing Isabelle without wasting time
Sabrina attacks the couple and then
tries to free Isabelle amidst the
commotion Elizabeth grabs a rod and
Strikes Isabel resulting in her demise
in retaliation Sabrina fights Elizabeth
and kicks her out through the window
causing her to fall to death shocked
Joseph immediately holds Sabrina by her
neck in an attempt to choke her to death
however she somehow manages to grab a
sharp wooden stick from the floor and
stabs it through his neck killing him he
always did get wood watching these
fights meanwhile Kurtz is at the party
when he detects an unsettling situation
this prompts him to head back to the
facility only to encounter Sabrina on
the elevator door before he can pull out
his gun Sabrina strikes him up with a
weapon and finishes him off with a knife
following this she walks out to the
party hall leaving the affluent
attendees stun she proceeds towards the
main gate and finally steps out into the
sunlight from there she runs across a
wooden bridge towards her Freedom
unfortunately her Escape is halted when
she is shot from behind by a guard who
turns out to be none other than Adam the
same guy from the first scene I knew the
guy named Adam would be a dick he is
revealed to be a recruiter who finds the
women and brings them to the facility
the movie ends with Sabrina having a
final vision of her daughter before
succumbing to her wounds subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching